Hallo Herrschaum, ich glaube es ist wegen des Heimlöses so warm.
Ich bin in diesem Moment im Internet, auf meinem Instagram.
Ich bin auf der Station als Arsitaner St.
Ich bin auf der Station, in der ich heute das Aufnahmegeschehen habe.
Habt ihr euch auch bekannt?
Natürlich, gerne.
Ja, ich bin auch an der Station in der St. Anne-Pärze.
Wie heißt ihr?
Mein Name ist Julia Hoffmann. Julia Hoffmann. Frau Hoffmann, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam ustabieren?
Mein Nachname ist H wie H, Heinrich, O wie Ot, F doppel F wie Friedrich, M wie Martha, A wie Anton, Doppel M wie Nordpol. Mein Vorname ist Julia, J, U wie Ulrich, L wie Ludwig, I wie Ida, A wie Anton.
Vielen Dank. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Hoffmann?
Ich bin 44 Jahre alt.
Ja, 44 Jahre alt sind Sie. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 25. Januar 1982.
1982.
1982, ok. Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Hoffmann?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter groß.
Ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich habe 72 Kilogramm.
72 Kilogramm, ok. Vielen Dank für die Information. Frau Hoffmann, was willst Du zu uns heute?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit ungefähr 5 Tagen Fieber habe.
5 Tage?
Ich komme heute von 39 Grad.
39 Grad, ok.
Ich habe Schmerzen in der rechten Flanke.
Rechte Flanke, Schmerzen haben Sie. Es tut mir sehr leid, Frau Hoffmann, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben. Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für diese Beschwerden?
Weiß ich nicht.
Seit 5 Tagen haben Sie rechte Flanke Schmerzen. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten, Frau Hoffmann?
Die sind zunehmend aufgetreten.
Zunehmend? Ok. Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich habe drückende, krampfartige Schmerzen.
Drückende, krampfartige Schmerzen haben Sie. Und wie lange dauert eine Attacke?
Die sind die ganze Zeit da.
Ok, krampfartige Schmerzen.
Und zunehmende Schmerzen haben Sie.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo aus, Frau Hoffmann?
Nein.
Nein. Im Laufe der Zeit sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden oder?
Wieso?
Im Laufe der Zeit sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden oder?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Ein bisschen. Ein bisschen. Ok. Könnten Sie mir bitte genau beschreiben, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10, wobei 0 kein Schmerzen, 10 sehr stärkste Schmerzen bedeutet? Wie würden Sie beschreiben?
Um 6 ungefähr.
6 ungefähr. Ok. Frau Hoffmann, ich habe bemerkt, Sie haben eine Stärke Schmerzen. Könnten Sie mich bis zum Ende aushalten oder möchten Sie ein Schmerzguck machen?
Ok, ja.
Ok. Frau Hoffmann, gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen verstärkt, zum Beispiel bei Bewegung oder?
Nein.
Nein. Gibt es noch etwas Linderth?
Schmerzproblemente.
Ok. Schmerzen. Was haben Sie dagegen angenommen?
Ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen. Wie viel Miligramm haben Sie?
600.
600. Ist das mit einem ärztlichen Rat oder?
Nein, ich habe die noch zu Hause gehabt. Ich habe sie selber genommen.
Ok. Frau Hoffmann, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, aber nehmen Sie bitte keinen ärztlichen Rat, kein Medikament ein.
Aber ich habe Schmerzen gehabt.
Ich verstehe, Sie haben natürlich recht. Frau Hoffmann, waren Sie deswegen bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Nein.
Nein. Ok. Ist das das erste Mal oder hatten Sie früher eine Beschwerd?
Das erste Mal.
Ist das das erste Mal? Ok. Und haben Sie Fieber?
Habe ich ja gesagt, neun, dreiviertel Tage.
Gestern Abend, neununddreißig.
Nein, nicht seit gestern. Seit fünf Tagen.
Fünf Tage. Seit fünf Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden. Und wissen Sie mehr als sonst?
Ich habe ein bisschen Schüttelfrost.
Ein bisschen Schüttelfrost. Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen.
Ok. Und dann haben Sie Schmerzen.
Müssen Sie häufig zum Wasser lassen?
Ja.
Wie viele Mal müssen Sie auf die Tüte?
Also ich muss immer wieder. So zehnmal am Tag bin ich auf Toilette.
Zehnmal am Tag. Und wie viele Menge?
Hier bitte.
Wie viele Menge haben Sie?
Hab ich nicht verstanden.
Ja. Haben Sie so viel Menge Wasser lassen oder?
Normal.
Ja. Normal. Ist das so?
Ja.
Ok. Ganz normal.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ich habe gestern das erste Mal Übelkeit und Erbrechen gehabt.
Übelkeit und Erbrechen. Nur einmal oder?
Einmal bisher. Nur gestern einmal.
Wie sah das Erbrochen aus?
Was ich gegessen habe.
Was Sie essen müssen.
Ok. Gibt es etwas, das die Gleichheit nicht aufgetreten ist und aufgefallen ist?
Zum Beispiel Kopfschmerzen, Schwindel, Kraftwerte.
Schwindel habe ich nicht. Nein. Aber Kopfschmerzen habe ich auch nicht.
Aber diese Fieber macht mir sehr zu schaffen.
Und diese kleinen Schmerzen.
Ja. Natürlich. Wie ist die Apothet?
Gut.
Apothet ist gut.
Und wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Also zwei Liter.
Ok. Zwei Liter trinken Sie.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen? Zum Beispiel ein brennendes Gefühl im Urin?
Haben Sie schon bemerkt?
Ja. Ein bisschen. Also leicht.
Ja. Leicht. Ok. Ein brennendes Gefühl.
Haben Sie eine Farbveränderung im Urin bemerkt?
Nein.
Nein. Ganz normal?
Normal.
Ja. Ok.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen rangen oder beschreiben?
Zu Beginn der Schmerzen war die rechte Flanke oder?
Rechte Flanke.
So 0,6 und 10.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturgang?
Nein.
Nein. Ok.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Apothet genannt?
Nein.
Nein. Ok.
Haben Sie geschwollenes Gelötete oder überwärmte Beine bemerkt?
Nein.
Ok. Und Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung bei Ihnen?
Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren.
Ca. fünf Jahren. Dagegen nehmen Sie...
Am April nehme ich ein.
Am April. Wie viel?
Einmal morgen.
Einmal morgen. Wie viel Milligramm?
Fünf Milligramm.
Fünf Milligramm. Ok. Was noch? Haben Sie noch irgendwelche...
Nein. Das darfst du.
Ok. Nehmen Sie irgendwie.
Frau Hoffmann, würden Sie schon einmal operiert oder?
Im Rahmen meiner Geburt. Ich habe einen Kaiserschnitt gehabt.
Kaiserschnitt. Wann war das?
2014.
2014. Ok. Was noch? Gibt es noch andere Operationen vorgestellt?
Bitte?
Nur Kaiserschnitt.
Nur das.
Ja. Ok. Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie noch Allergie?
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Keine Allergie. Gibt es noch eine Unverträglichkeit gegen etwas?
Nicht das.
Ok. Nehmen Sie als Medikament Amlodipin. Fünf Milligramm. Einmal.
RamiPri.
RamiPri. Entschuldigung. RamiPri. Und bei Bedarf über Profan 600.
Genau.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nein.
Ok. Frau Hoffmann, rauchen Sie?
Ich bin nicht Raucher.
Nicht Raucher. Super. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten. Vielleicht zweimal im Jahr oder dreimal im Jahr.
Ok. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
In meiner Jugend habe ich das mal gemacht.
Ok. Ok. Frau Hoffmann, sind Sie 40 Jahre alt und bekommen Sie Ihre Periopädie?
Ja. 44 Jahre.
Ja. Und?
Ja. Alles ist normal.
Alles in Ordnung. Und verhauten Sie?
Momentan nicht.
Ok. Kein Problem. Frau Hoffmann, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja. Mein Vater hat auch Bluthochdruck und meine Mutter hat Zucker.
Oh, Zucker. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind. Ok. Und Frau Hoffmann, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Genau. Ein Kind habe ich.
Ein Kind. Ist er oder sie gesund?
Ja.
Ok. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Industriekauffrau.
Industriekauffrau, Industriekauffrau.
Frau Hoffmann, ich würde nochmal fragen, haben Sie im Ring zum Beispiel Blut oder so etwas nicht bemerkt?
Nein.
Seit fünf Tagen haben Sie 39 Grad Celsius Fieber.
Genau.
Einmal haben Sie das Erbruch.
Gestern.
Und das war Essenreste. Und haben Sie rechtseitige Flankschmerzen. Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Richtig.
Ja, ok. Vielen Dank. Gibt es im Urin eine Trübung oder nicht bemerkt?
Der Urin ist unauffällig.
Ohne Trübung?
Ok. Vielen Dank, Frau Hoffmann.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit. Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich habe keine Fragen.
Ok. Ich habe einen Verdacht auf. Nielenentzündung.
Ok.
Und natürlich ist das ein Verdachtstdiagnos. Das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen und einen Ultraschall durchführen.
Dann, sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen, bespreche ich mit meinem Obers und komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erzähle Ihnen Schritt für Schritt alles.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank, Frau Hoffmann.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Frau Hoffmann, leiden Sie unter Schmerzen beim Geschlechtsverkehr?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie auch einen vaginalen Ausfuhr?
Nein.
Ok. Danke.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Frau Hoffmann, entschuldigen Sie, wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen? Achselhöhle oder?
Hier, unter Namen.
Ok. Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Obers. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen. Wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen ihn vorstellen.
Bitte schön.
Ok. Es geht um eine Frau Julia Hoffmann, 44 Jahre alt, geboren am 25.01.1982. Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und sie wiegt 72 Kilo.
Frau Julia Hoffmann stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seines fünf Tagen bestehenden, persistierenden, prognodierten rechtzeitigen Flankschmerzen vor.
Sie berichtet, dass sie früher keine Ähnliches beschwerden hat. Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen drückend und rammfertig und ausgetragen würdeverneint.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS. Dagegen nimmt sie überproffens 600 Milligramm mehrmals ein.
Die Schmerzen sind seit fünf Tagen bestehende Fieber- und Schitterfrost und Polakusidie täglich ca. 10 Mal.
Die Urinmenge ist normal und seit fünf Tagen Übelkeit und einmal Erbrüchen. Die Konsistenz war Essenreste.
Sie trinkt ca. zwei Liter Wasser täglich und sie hat seit fünf Tagen ein brennendes Gefühl.
Ansonsten ist die Vegetative an Amnesie unauffällig. Als Vorerkrankung an Amnesie leidet sie an arteriell Hypatonie seit fünf Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie am April fünf Milligramm einmal morgen regelmäßig. Bei der Voroperation an Amnesie erwähnt sie nur eine kreise Sexuelsesare im Jahr 2014.
Sie hat keine Allergie und bei der Medikamentanamnesie erwähnt sie außer Amepril die Einnahme von überproffens 600 Milligramm.
Bei der Nuchsenanamnesie erwähnt sie nur lediglich ein oder zwei Gläser Wein oder Bier im Jahr pro Jahr und Drogen und Nikotin konsumt unauffällig.
Die Familienanamnesie ergab arteriell Hypatonie beim Vater, Diabetes mellitus Typ 2 bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnestisch ist sie Industriekauffrau verheiratet. Sie hat ein Kind. Aufgrund der Anamnesie habe ich den Verdacht auf ein Pylonephritis, bestehende Fieber, rechtseitige Flankschmerzen, Vomitus, Neuser.
Täglich sehen wir Polakysurin und ein rennender Gefühl bei Urin. Die Pylonephritis kann sehr diagnostisch kommen.
Ich werde eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen. Im Labor werde ich ein großes Blutbild und Leber- und Nierenwerte, Ernstundungwerte,
CAP, Blutsenkung, Geschwindigkeit und gegebenen Fast Prokastonin und Cholestasenzyme und Urinstatus und Urinkultur kontrollieren lassen.
Als wirgebender Verfahren werde ich einen Ultraschall, Nieren- und Bauchultraschall durchführen, sowie einen Rücken- und Bauch.
Das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht. Warum möchten Sie einen Rücken machen?
Ich brauche Urolithiasis und Cholidocholithiasis. Deswegen ein Stein.
Braucht man dafür Röntgen-Kontrastmittel?
Nein, Röntgen.
Auch mal nicht. Aber normales könnte man es machen.
Ist es besser ein Stein zu machen, ein CT zu machen?
Ein Loswurf-CT?
Ja, natürlich. Aber das muss ohne Kontrastmittel sein.
Ist CT nicht besser als Röntgen?
Nein.
Für die Steindiagnose Röntgen ist genug aus meiner Sicht.
Das ist eine medizinische Sicht. Deswegen steht ein Nieren- und Ultraschall und ein Rücken.
Wenn Sie die Diagnose bestätigt haben, welche Therapie leiten Sie ein?
Sollte sich die Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen, empfehle ich eine Stationale.
Ich werde die Patienten stationär aufgenommen.
An erster Stelle steht eine Füßigkeit zuvor.
Gegebenenfalls Elektrolyssubstitution und Analgetikum und Antispasmolytikum schlage ich vor.
Und je nach Ergebnis der Urinkultur, verabreiche ich ein Antibiotikum.
Machen Sie auch Antipyrütika?
Ja. Ich werde zum Beispiel einen kümilarischen Antibiotikum.
Das könnte Ampicillin-Sulbaktam oder die zweite Generasi...
Antibiotika.
Nein. Antipyrätika.
Antipyrise.
Ja, natürlich. Zum Beispiel Paracetamol.
Paracetamol oder Nomagin.
Analgetikum, Antipyrätikum und Antispasmolytikum.
Und vielleicht Antibiotika.
Ja. Normalerweise werde ich am Anfang eine kümilarische Antibiotik verabreichen.
Eine was? Antikülerische?
Kümilarische. Ampirische Antibiotik. Ampirische. Zum Beispiel Ampicillin oder die zweite Generasi.
Antikülerisch habe ich nicht verstanden.
In unseren Texten steht die kümilarische Antibiotik.
Kümilarische oder Kalkulierte?
Kalkulierte. Kalkulierte Antibiotik.
Kalkulierte.
Ok. Sehr gut. Vielen Dank. Können Sie einmal stoppen?
Ja, auf gehts.